Gabriel glass that comes in with some
crazy looking cholo like like this guy
wasn't they caught up killer what they
call a [ __ ] oh no I was indignant cholo
and I like the guy he was cool with me
yeah you could probably smell your
history on it we like this guy knows I
like the guy in he walked out to me like
a dog like pretty much trying to
intimidate me a homie my homie over here
wants to do his comedy game you want to
know you be able o shot and say was your
home yet
over there that fat [ __ ] all and I just
looked at her asleep while you told me
I'm fat [ __ ] if you also spot he has to
ask me himself because he can't be
taking you everywhere so sooner or later
he's gonna have to speak up for himself
boom goes your ride homie your ride
homie so we're over there and talk to
him and he walked over to me like our 8
year old boy hey man ok so I said sure
bro
you're next they're all eight perfect
put them up like 15 of em you know like
a young comic yeah you have dick jokes
and he did like voices and all his
voices were dick jokes this is my
presentation of Marlon the Martian
having sex
he might monk you later you know this
guy from MTV those guys got the name of
the show their car to Beaver Simba and
his beavers above his having had having
give me some air you know what the Ross
sexual jokes mm-hmm but out but people
love there were nothing I was like that
you know they were there was only power
of Francisco and eros Pierce I guess I
don't know you I didn't know him at the
time and they were the only one they
were doing like noise this James and
James Anthony no J James Anthony the
third or James Evans at there was
another guy who did like voices and Luke
Torres keeper
the best one of all of them he said in
Hebrew so check this out
he's because he got my friend right away
and I told him just follow me wherever I
go
so we would go to places and perform and
a lot of play they didn't let him go out
because there know who he was was a fat
guy with bad teeth he was like not even
21 yet he was 20 and there was what time
um he was he wanted he never hosted a
show well bro you what I mean so when a
hold to show I can host it okay you're
gonna host our whole show so he hosted
the whole show and they know we're all
right brothers what happened other you
don't go over there and that manager is
gonna give you a slip let's gonna say
$75 on it give me all of it so it's my
turn now uh-huh yeah a finder's fee so I
think you me all of it uh-huh so then
his [ __ ] ass is complaining bro I never
could wait I never complained I never to
anybody what the deal was with the money
nobody knew so he went to go tell Jeff
right whoa that's ball I can cry little
[ __ ] Jeff what is Jeff gonna do bro
he's 22 he's young he's like 17 19 years
old Gabriel's age you know what's a back
dagger are you [ __ ] don't get fat ass
no money he goes at least when I when I
have you sign I give you 435 you keep 40
and I said really right now go call him
over here so the three of us and I said
man besides me who else have let you
host or put your shows who else me who
has given you money no one right bro I
give you I you got a free lesson in
stand-up comedy I'm hosting you got to
perform for about an hour
got to go try new jokes no one is gonna
give you that don't you ever cry about
money ever in your life
it's a great lesson for all come ever
cry about how much you guys are nothing
at this cuz you're gonna make money in
the future he may leave me a little bit
yeah so he was always business minded I
guess from the jump he was always well
he had a job no one else had a job oh
okay yeah he had a job at the Evert like
a kiosk selling t mobile phones or
Verizon phones or singular for whatever
yeah but he's in like the 1% of comedy
now like he's I mean he's he's like cut
top 7 right it's incredible like just
just the Empire he's been able to build
yeah man and like what do you is is that
something you saw in him early on is
like there's something about him or what
do you attribute to that and you've been
on the road with a most below like what
did you learn impersonation and all that
okay we like that yeah but we ended up
opening I ended up on working with him
and half of his act
Isabella about me right so he's
imitating me too right and doing my
newest sons and kind of doing my jokes
too so I say listen man